what about the foot baths? Can you increase them or how often can you do them?
So you could do a foot bath, you could do a foot bath every day, if you want.
The foot bath, so the foot bath with the rife with the true rife machine, you could do every day.
Now there's other foot bath apparatus in some of their that are called ion cleanses
and that works on a very different principle. The foot bath with the rife is
is just another way to administer frequencies. The ion cleanses that are out there, and you might
have gone to a clinic that used an ion cleanse. That is completely different. That is ionizing the
water positive or negative, and then pulling out the opposite ions. And that does pull a lot of
electrolytes. And if you're going to do an ion cleanse foot bath every day, you could still do that
every day, but that makes sure you're you're getting greens right again, or you're taking it
extra mineral pill, because you don't want to just be pulling minerals out of your body.
Right. The ion I use the ion pro wave and the 3D talk programs, and I rotate them.
Yeah, you're fine with that. You could do that every day. I find with that.
Yes.